something very special happens daily at
findlay toyota i dropped in on john barr
in findlay toyota who are sponsoring
this segment to learn more
look it's john barr
good to see you good to see you john
good to see you good to see you you know
we have something that happens really
special here every day oh i know what it
is here fiddly toyota um great savings
for customers well that you get that but
that wasn't what i was thinking amazing
customer service
hopefully you get that you better i know
what it is every day you talk to your
employees about soccer that is the
problem but that's not the one i'm
thinking i give up what is it we have
new cars arriving here daily every day
every day in these times how you getting
new cars every day toyota are looking
after us it's no problem we're getting
400 plus new cars a month so these
tacomas behind us here are these all
brand new trucks they are all brand new
all brand new now i've got buddies that
are looking at tacomas right now but
they're looking at the used market i
didn't realize you have so many brand
new tacomas we do and the crazy thing is
is with the pricing on the used ones you
can get a new one here for the money you
pay for a two or three year old one
anywhere else how are you doing this how
you pulling this off everybody hey is
the toyota giving us the cars i mean we
cannot argue about that they're giving
us the vehicles and they're going to
continue to come they come a certain way
though we don't have a lot sitting on
the ground right now we've got 12 cars
here but we'll have three trucks arrived
today every day 20 30 cars arriving that
is huge now when a car comes here or
tacoma comes here it doesn't just roll
off the truck and out onto the street
what's the process now it goes through a
pdi process which is pre-delivery
inspection i'll show you that okay
sounds good let's go going to pdi after
you john we're in the pdi area of
findlay toyota john i feel like there's
magic happening back there there is
actually this is where the cars come
before they go anywhere they come to pdi
free delivery inspection we deal with
safety and everything checked out on
these vehicles then once that part of
the process is done
uh we then go to where we tint them we
do the door edge guards we do all the
other necessary things to make them
pretty but predominantly to protect the
customer from the sun you tint every
single new car that comes through every
one of them you guys are absolutely
amazing well thank you we appreciate it
and someone told me there's something
very special going on in service right
now it's tied into the holidays we do
should we go over there and have a look
all the way it's your dealership i'll
just follow you
we've actually got something very
special going on in service right now
what we're going to do is give a 20
discount to any service ticket if you
bring in a new toy for some jude's ranch
great cause hold one second
i
brought a new toy
wow i love this
love it yes here's the thing though this
is a great toy for a kid to assemble the
toyota supra someone watching right now
they wanted one of these i didn't see it
out on the lot can you get them one we
can give them that yes we can we can get
them anything they want they just might
have to wait a little while because it's
an ordering process that we have to get
through and obviously we can get the car
it might take 60 days it might take 90
days but we'll get the car it's worth
the wait for the toyota supra john thank
you so much appreciate it always happy
holidays
thank you again to finlay toyota for
sponsoring this segment visit them at
7733 eastgate road in henderson or call
them at
702-566-2596 or visit them online at
findlaytoyota.com